تتواصل عمليات نزوح السودانيين الفرين
لمصر العبارات النيليه ترسو في ابو سمبل
بشكل يومي وعلمتها شيوخ وشباب واطفال
ونساء فتره راحه قصيره قبل استئناف الرحله
الى مدينه اسوان علامات الارهاق لم تمنعه
من الحديث الغاضب عما تركوه خلفهم ومن
المجهول الذي ينتظرهم ما عندها حاجه ناس
تعبانه ناس تشردت دي المشكله هنا الواحد
منظر كمان لاخوانه التانين يعني
في الاسواق ما في كهرباء ما في مويه ما في
اي حاجه ومن داخل هذه الحافله يبدا الجزء
الثاني من الرحله الطويله والمرهقه الى
مدينه اسوان
توجهنا معهم الى اسوان حيث بدات تامل
الحزين والتفكير في المستقبل واضحا على
الوجوه وفي موقف كركر في اسوان تتوقف
الحافلات البعض يستقل حافلات اخرى الى
القاهره اما الاغلبيه فسوف تستقر في اسوان
حي الصداقه المعروف منذ اعوام بانه التجمع
الاكبر لابناء الجاليه السودانيه يبدو
مقتزا بالوافدين الجدد السودانيون
المقيمون لا يتوقفون عن الحديث عما يدور
في بلادهم من اقتتال اذا زول امشي معنا
عادي من سوء ونوديه
مشكل عادي يعني انه كونه يستجيب اخواننا
السودانيين نحن واحد وفي احدى ضواحي
المدينه التقينا بمجموعه من الوافدين
سودانيون من المقيمين كانوا في انتظارهم
لتوفير السكن وفرص العمل ممن لا يملكون
الاموال يمنعنا كلنا مع بعض وان شاء الله
رب العالمين حنقدر نوفر اي زور حتى فرص
العمل دي هنتفق مع شباب مصريين الحمد لله
انه عارفين يا شباب كميه من المصريين
هيتفق معهم انه اعمال ان شاء الله بسيطه
لاي سوداني ونقدر نتصرف معاه في الحاجه دي
عبد الحكم الذي تجاوز الخمسين من العمر
يسعى لعلاج زوجته المريضه تنقصه الاموال
ويبحث عن فرصه عمل ليتمكن من علاجها انا
جاي معاه عشان ادور لشغل وان شاء الله هو
عالجه عشان اقف معها ان شاء الله وان شاء
الله وجزاكم عند الله خير وبارك الله فيكم
قصص السودانيين القادمين لمصر قد تتشابه
في تفاصيل رحلات الهروب ولكنها تتنوع في
تفاصيل المصائر مما قد يحمله لهم قادم
الايام احمد عثمان العربيه مدينه اسوان
قاتل
اشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات